we always kind of say we shouldn't have
a story but we should have a law there
is a consistent narrative the things
that you see they're there for a reason
if there are buildings they're there
because a certain race built them and
they look like that race has built them
and we talked to aliens in the game
you'll get little touches of that if you
read some text on a monolith you all get
you know it will be consistent with that
and that's lower to me that's world
building
I used to love space opera I loved the
grand scale stuff I love the kind of
stuff that Larry Niven would do or
people out Robert Heinlein well the
thing is with no man's sky it's such a
kind of comprehensive universe i'm going
to guess almost by definition the
universe has to be comprehensive but
it's got such scope that in our early
discussions we came to the conclusion
you could settle kinds of stories within
that universe you could write virtually
any kind of science fiction exploration
battle trading love story anything you
wanted
much as I'm thrilled to go and see a new
game and to get the inside scoop on it
because I am a fan you know I just think
I'm seeing something that other people
haven't seen them I've got inside
knowledge they seem to be equally
thrilled to meet me because I done a lot
of things that they like Watchmen
obviously one of the pre pre eminent
things there I floated the idea you know
maybe we could do a comic or graphic
novel or something and they seem to
think that was a really good idea first
of all we explored doing it as a
standalone item but then we thought it
would be really good way just to get our
feet wet to do something that could be
included with the game that that would
add value to that
I've always had a soft spot for old
games when you used to buy them and they
would come with like a booklet I liked
the idea of that for an immense guy of
giving people a little bit of flavor of
the universe and kind of helped build
out the world a little bit I chose to
tell a story that was a kind of small
adventure about a trader with a very
valuable cargo and what becomes of the
cargo because that trading aspect was
one part of the game so it's a lot of
flying about in spaceships and a bit of
humor I think and it's worked really
well because in this booklet that's
going to be with the game James swallow
who wrote a text story wrote a more
visceral internal very gripping and
engaging story one particular character
I connect very strongly with visual
imagery and I think the look of no man's
sky was the thing that really sort of
struck me when I when I saw it the first
time because it had that look like all
of my favorite pulp sci-fi covers come
to life and immediately when I saw that
very first trailer I thought I've got to
play this I want to go to this place I
want to wander around there and then you
know and seal it love it and it was just
it was inspiring it's been great to have
Dave doing these illustrations to sort
of you know bookend my story we've done
something in a way that's kind of
similar to the old sort of Pulp sci-fi
magazines like you know galaxy magazine
and the standing stories and all those
kind of things whether you have a text
story you have these kind of great
black-and-white illustrations and having
those two things married together I
think again it's all this stuff is
reaching back to the to the to the law
in the sense of the world that this
science fiction has come from and it's
it's fun to explore that so what I've
done is it's a survival story it's about
a character who's a shipwrecked on the
planet with some unpleasant alien
species chasing after them and we got
the Sentinels that you've seen in the
game as well and it's all about this
character just basically trying to fix
their ship and get off the planet but
it's very much done from an internal
viewpoint made it very personal and I
felt like I was trying to explore that
world and explore that sort of texture
what's been really fun with James with
dave is actually just showing them the
game especially like people who have
such a love of sci-fi and such a
background in it but also what's
happened is then working on the fiction
and which is just kind of set in our
universe actually lots of the questions
that they asked you suddenly think what
we either don't know that for sure or we
haven't like locked it down or right we
need to lock this down like how does
this work how does you know and it's
crazy things it's like how does the
landing gear of a ship work and suddenly
James will ask you that I don't thought
about that you know but I should I'm not
sure even I know the whole story yet but
I do like the idea of adventures
happening in the universe that has a
history you know that you're not really
the first people who ever flew around
this universe so I like that idea of
trying to piece together a mystery as
well you know not only to physically
explore but intellectually to piece
together a mystery
I think there's definitely a huge
breadth of stories to tell in no man's
sky it is a systemic game because it is
about you interacting with the
environment and the characters and
there's no sort of hardcore narrative
that says you must do this you must do
this and you must do this what's unique
about that is this is something that
games can do that no other sort of form
of storytelling ken is you as a player
can come in and you can build your own
narrative and you might play that game
for you know months or years who knows
how long but at the end of your play of
no man's sky you will have told the
story that will be unique to you and
that I think that that is that is
incredible
ps4 for the players